hey everyone welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel today we will learn how
to install MySQL and windows but before
we begin if these are the type of videos
you'd like to watch then hit that like
And subscribe button and the bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
Lear just for a quick info if you want
to upskill yourself master data science
and data analytics skills and landar
your dream job or growing your career
then you must explore simply learn score
various data science and business
analytics programs simply learn offer
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some leading
experts and universities like calch
Purdue and IIT conord and much more
through these courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like Advanced Excel python
machine learning data visualization
generative Ai and over a dozen of others
that's not all you also get the
opportunity to work on multiple projects
and learn from industry experts working
in Top Tire data and product companies
and academic from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitions into data
science or analytics rule as a pressure
or moved onto a higher paying job or
profile if you are passionate about
making your career in this field then
make sure to check out the link in the
print comment and description box to
find a data science and analytics
program that fits your experience and
areas of Ence now without further deil
let's get started with how to install
MySQL in Windows to install MySQL let's
go to Google and now let's open the
official website of MySQL workbench so
you have to type MySQL download and go
to the first link which will take you to
the myql workbench homepage now scroll
down and you can see my SQL Community
downloads click on that and here you can
see a lot of options go for my SQL
install for Windows then here check your
version let's select the latest one and
let's select operating system is Windows
you have MSI installer and MSI installer
two go to the second option which is
about 200 MB not the first one now just
click on no thanks just start my
download and now go to downloads there
you go your installer file is getting
downloaded let's wait for a few
seconds now the my SQL installer has
been downloaded show in folder run that
particular
installer provide any admin rights if
you are having admin permissions if you
don't have any admin rights I think the
installation should start right
away there you go the install has
started after giving the admin rights I
think this should be the last admin
rights and then the installation should
go
on there you go the install has been
started now here we have various options
server only client full custom if you
don't have any idea then go to full but
in case if you have idea about what
you're going to install I would
recommend go to custom and select the
server workbench and a few other things
and that should be good so let me go for
servers first that's a server my SQL
Server 8.0 that's the one we need and if
you need shell you can also go to Shell
and the most important one for today's
session is about the workbench so
anyways let's take the server and then
the shell and also the workbench the
drag and drop is not working I think we
can select the arrow there's the
workbench next is the shell and after
that we should be selecting our server
there you go now next and execute all
these three will be installed
soon I think they have got installed now
yeah I think we should go to next one
last check once yeah so next next and
here just check the port numbers and I
would like to go with the default port
number here no changes
and next and here we have two use Legacy
authentication but I would go with the
recommended one now provide password for
your workbench choose the password that
you would like to remember that's my
first password and I'll be repeating the
same password Here for confirmation and
next there you go let's have a standard
system account Grant full access to my
SQL and now execute so that all these
configurations get applied to your
installation we have started
now your workbench has been started
double click and now give a password
that you gave during the configuration
enter and that's how you install
workbench in your local Windows system
now you can create new models new
databases Etc and you can run a default
command which is show databases which
will show you the default databases that
are readily available for you to work on
on the my SQL workbench on vendors the
command is show databases and semicolon
but now let's run the default commands
and as the series come down from Simply
learn on SQL you will learn more SQL
tutorials so that's the show databases
command r that class symbol and there
you go you have the default databases
that's how you install MySQL workbench
in Microsoft Windows and with that we
have come to the end of this session on
how to install my SQL in Windows
operating system and if you any of the
resources that we used in this session
like the links or anything please do let
us know in the comment section below and
our te of experts we'll be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you for
watching and St for more from simp
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domain domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here